have you ever noticed that stocks
plummet right when you buy them
this is one of the most common rants on
investing subreddits and the youtube
comments section
however this situation doesn't seem like
it's limited to just new investors
either
even seasoned investors with millions in
the market like meet kevin
and graham stefan have also expressed
similar sentiments
in the past so why do stocks always go
down
right when we buy them well
starting off this experience isn't just
random bad luck
there's actually several legitimate
explanations for this phenomenon
beginning with the market cycle all free
markets in the world
experience spreads of positivity and
excitement and segments of negativity
and despair and the truth is me and us
retail investors
likely get in during the worst time
possible stock rallies often start with
the genuine optimism for a fundamentally
positive change
for a given company for instance tesla
might have had their first profitable
year
or apple might have announced that
they're increasing iphone production
these are both genuinely good signs for
the company long term
and get many investors excited however
if you're getting in
after such news comes out you're likely
already late
here's the thing hedge funds and savvy
investors have likely been frontrunning
such news
for weeks if not months in many cases
they have access to insider information
but even without insider information
it's not too terribly difficult to be
one step ahead of retail investors
this isn't to say that retail investors
are stupid per se
but we have to keep in mind that big
money guys have often been investing and
trading for decades
and they do it as a full-time job so
it's not surprising that they would at
least be a bit ahead of retail investors
anyways this is the optimism stage of
the market cycle
and it is the most profitable stage
after this
we head into the enthusiasm stage this
is the time that more experienced retail
traders
as well as lacking big money gets into
this stock
these guys don't always know why the
stock is actually going up
but they see large amounts of volume
buying and figured that bigger hedge
funds and market makers
know something that they don't at this
point the expected news hasn't even come
out yet
but smart money is already fully in and
will likely not be adding to their
position
and this is when we finally see the news
actually come out
cnbc and bloomberg will report that
amazon had a blowout quarter
or the tesla's launching full
self-driving traders who are glued to
the news will quickly jump onto the
opportunity
often leading to a sudden jump in stock
price momentum traders with alerts for
some stock movements will also get
alerted
and jump on the train causing the stock
price to move up even further
unfortunately this is the point that the
average retail investor will hear about
the positive news
but by this time we have already
completed the optimism stage
the enthusiasm stage in the exuberance
stage
now all that's left is the euphoria
generally this stage doesn't last too
long as most cycles don't attract too
many retail investors
once in a while though we'll see a piece
of news travel quite far through social
media
youtubers and tick-tockers might jump
onto apple making electric vehicle
or microsoft completing an acquisition
elon might even tweet about it
it's definitely possible to make money
during this stage depending on how many
retail investors jump on board
but there is really no logic behind the
stock price anymore
it's really just a game of hot potato
between retail investors
as long as people are able to flip
shares for a higher price to other
retail investors
the cycle will continue at one point
though
either the retail investors will get
exhausted from bidding up the stock
or the market makers will decide that
it's time to rent in the party
considering that institutional investors
account for 70 of stock trading volume
it's not hard for hedge funds and market
movers to ground stock after a massive
run-up
moreover a lot of euphoric run-ups are
fueled by low volume trading
so when a big red candle pops up in the
chart it's clear that something is about
to change
and this leads us into the anxiety phase
smart money has
already started selling but retail
investors who think it's just a dip will
end up buying the dip
and momentarily pop up the stock price
despite their efforts though
institutional selling will start to pick
up speed as hedge funds look to lock in
their profits
before buyers dry up lagging hedge funds
and savvy retail traders will start to
pick up on the beginning
of a downtrend and they too will sell
which leads us into the stage
of denial people who bought at the top
start to realize that maybe they were
too late to party
but they still have a sliver of hope
that maybe we'll see another tweet from
elon
or that some surprise news will save
them in reality
these guys were the people who ended up
with the potato and the music stopped
as more early traders take profits the
stock price will continue to move down
and will soon find ourselves in the
stages of fear despair
and of course panic some retail traders
will wisely just cut losses
and move on right when fear hits but
others will continue to hold on despite
despair sending in
despair is the stage at which the stock
price returns to the level
at which it started to rally and though
traders who are still holding are down a
decent bit
most of them believe that can't get much
worse however
this is when hedge funds will step in
once again
the hedge fund likely spotted another
news opportunity coming up
where they can make some more profits
but they don't want to reinvigorate a
potential rally before they're able to
fully get in
so they'll go out and sell some of their
long-term position
and maybe throw out some fear-filled
articles to cause the stock price to dip
just a little bit more
and this light push over the edge is all
that's needed to cause a flurry of
selling
you see many traders will set their
stop-loss just under the price at which
the rally started
hedge funds will take advantage of this
and sell just enough to trigger these
stop losses
which will quickly lead to a way of
panic selling leading us into stage of
capitulation
and discouragement in these stages most
retail traders
have already forfeited trying to come
out positive from the trade and have
sold out their positions for a loss
but just as this may start to set in
hedge funds will buy back the positions
they sold to create the panic selling
in the first place and as they start to
front run the next news cycle
we'll start to see hope relief and
optimism re-enter the stock market
causing the cycle to start all over
again as you can see
institutional investors aren't using any
voodoo magic or anything like that
they're just buying low and selling high
just like everyone else
however the key difference is that their
entry and exit point cycle
is exactly the inverse of retail
investors which often results in retail
investors buying right at the top
and selling price at the bottom this
brings up another question though
how is their entry and exit points
always the profitable ones
well aside from being professionals they
have another key piece of technology
under their sleeve which is algorithmic
trading
algorithmic trading is exactly what it
sounds like this
is when hedge funds or individuals trade
based on recommendations from an
algorithm
these algorithms aren't based on news or
financial reports or anything
fundamental about the underlying company
rather these algorithms are based on
volume stock price
and most importantly human psychology
long-term stock investing
is all about the fundamentals of a
company and an industry as a whole
but short-term stock trading really has
nothing to do with the underlying
company
sure good fundamental news may act as a
short-term catalyst
however the key to long-term
profitability as a stock trader is
understanding human psychology
how much does the stock have to go up
before people start to fomo in
once people start to form a win how long
will euphoria and hype last
similarly how fast does a given stock
have to drop before people start to pan
excel
and how long will panic selling last
speaking of human psychology
something else to keep in mind is that
you're much more likely to remember the
time you were down on a trade
as opposed to the time you were up on a
trade because our brains are wired to
remember pain so that we don't repeat
the same mistakes
as we just discussed when we're looking
at stock's movement over the short term
it's really just a coin flip as to
whether it's going up or down
thus you were likely down right after
you bought roughly 50
of the time even if the stock recovers
and you make a ton of money down the
road
you're likely to always remember how you
were down right after you bought it
and this simply feels a notion that
stocks go down right when you buy them
in reality though you actually made a
great call and it's simply impossible to
perfectly time the market
anyways over the years big money and
their algorithms have mastered how
humans behave under various
circumstances
thus they are able to pretty
consistently make money while 80
of day traders lose money even if you're
not a day trader and simply trying to
build out a long-term position
you'll often find yourself in the same
boat you buy into what you think
is a solid dip buying opportunity but
the stock just continues to go downwards
because hedge funds and their algorithms
are once again one step ahead
the difference here is that long-term
investors will simply continue to
average down
and have no problem holding the company
until it recovers because they have a
strong conviction
in the business with traders on the
other hand most of them
aren't disciplined and don't have a game
plan which often ends in them panic
selling and
blaming the stock market you might think
that what big money does
is unfair and it is true that many of
their practices
are predatory and really are unfair
but at the end of the day the stock
market is simply a game to transfer
money from someone else's account
to your account and when you enter the
arena you have to keep in mind that
there are so many pro players who have
been added
for decades so why do stocks always go
down right when you buy them
well you either bought in and the hedge
funds market makers and their algorithms
got the better of you either momentarily
or permanently or ufo mode in
and didn't have a plan have you guys
ever bought stocks
and if so have you guys ever experienced
a phenomenon of stock dipping right
after you buy them
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video provided
a thorough analysis
as to why exactly that happens and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions largely answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one